Welcome to "Ear Biscuits".
I'm Rhett.
And I'm Link.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we're gonna talk about
stuff that you've told us
that you're really into.
And we're probably gonna rip it to shreds.
No, we're just gonna process it.
And assess it.
We're gonna help you.
We're gonna assess it.
If you need to abandon this thing,
we'll let you know that.
If we have some advice that we think
that you need to hear as you
approach liking this thing,
we're just gonna give some perspective.
What so we know?
And let me tell you.
Well, I'll tell you what.
We know that we've got brains.
This bearded man right here next to me
certainly been into a
lot of different stuff.
If you haven't listened
to our Rhett's layers
episode from way back.
Oh, throwback.
If you wanna pick apart what Rhett's into
or has been into in fleeting fashion
over the many years that I've known him--
I don't like that.
That's a good episode.
I took issue with that character relation.
To listen to.
With my layers.
But we're both into things.
And so we're qualified to assess
if other people's stuff that
they're into is worth it.
I'll tell you, there's some,
I almost said some strange addictions
but it's borderline
strange addiction stuff
that's happening here and just
some odd unexpected things
that I think it's important
that we talk about.
So--
Well, that might be over selling it.
I think we got to oversell it.
I mean I think if this,
I'm just trying
to be honest here.
Every time I tease
an episode, you immediately
rip it to shreds.
Go with me.
You're too sensational.
Because I would say if
you went your entire life
without hearing the things
that we're about to say,
you'd probably be okay.
You don't know what we're about to say.
I mean, I'm saying that's you
my best guess at this point.
Listen, I'm gonna say some stuff--
I think you're gonna have a good time.
That's gonna change your life.
I think you're gonna have a good time,
I think that you're gonna,
hopefully, you're gonna laugh,
hopefully, you're gonna feel
like this was a good use of your time
and that you were entertained
and if you were one of the individuals
that we will be addressing,
maybe this could be life-changing
but for just the average person listening
who didn't submit one of these things,
you can kinda take it or leave it.
Well, it's not even do it.
Hold on, you gotta
understand what I'm doing.
I'm doing a reverse psychology.
You're doing what you've
learned in 20 years of marriage.
Right.
Lower the bar.
Yes, because then they'll think,
really, man, you know what,
I'm really glad I listened
and Rhett told me that I wouldn't be.
Then the next time, they'll be like,
maybe it's always worth listening.
This episode's gonna
suck but if you love us,
you'll stick with us.
I'll tell you something
I'm into right off the bat
because something happened
to me and it was strange.
I'm getting really into physical therapy
because I've been into
physical fitness but it might--
That's an interesting thing to get into.
In our age--
Usually, physical therapy
is something you get into
because you were prescribed
it for a specific condition.
And I was.
I currently have a prescription
for physical therapy
sitting in my car unused.
Yeah, that's called a
you're a card-carrying
middle-aged man is
basically what that means.
I'm into physical fitness, which at my age
means I'm into physical therapy.
I think that when you're thinking,
if you go into a gym and
they give you a contract,
just go ahead and say,
okay, I'm gonna add in
the cost of physical
therapy on top of this.
Let me just say, I--
Completely agree.
I completely disagree with you
because I'm not saying that working out
doesn't make you injury
prone but not working out
makes you more injury prone,
definitely, than you would have been.
Because listen, my back is in better shape
than it's ever been,
hasn't caused me trouble
and I firmly believe it is because
I have been the most consistent
with my fitness regimen.
Well--
So, I think that some of those injuries,
like I know you've got a bad shoulder,
I've got a bad shoulder,
I got the bad knee now,
hopefully that's getting better
but I have to believe that it's not as bad
as if I was just in atrophy all the time.
I started going to the gym years ago
because my right shoulder was hurting
and I went to physical therapy for a while
and it made it better and
then I wanted to maintain.
But then, my left
shoulder started hurting.
I said you know what,
I need to get back to--
It felt left out.
Some physical therapy
to just get this thing
hanging right again or something.
I don't know what.
We both been in a physical therapy.
I prefer, I've been in the
two types of physical therapy.
There's the one where
you're in a large room
with a lot of other people.
Yeah.
And then there's the one where
I have a physical therapist
that I go to from time to time,
she just has an office and it's just her
and you're in an office and that's it.
And that second scenario
has proven much more
effective for me, personally.
I know you've experimented
with both as well
but now, you're going
to the open area again.
It's an open area but it's
one-on-one physical therapy
and there's not, sometimes,
there's one other person
in there, usually.
Because I went to one
where they rotated on me.
Yeah, I did that too.
That's a bit personal.
That's no good.
You feel like cattle.
Yeah.
Some focus.
Anyway, I go in there
and, I'll just use the first name Jane.
Is that real?
Did I learn my lesson to not,
should I call her PT Patti?
This is not,
well, who knows?
I don't think my story's incriminating
then I start telling them
and they probably are.
But I love Jane.
She's a great person,
I give her five stars on my review, okay?
If you were to leave one.
But you know, when your
therapy is Link Neal,
I guess you get in a weird territory
so I'll say that it's on me, not on her
but here's what happened.
I go in there, I'm hyper
mobile and my shoulders,
I'm not doing my exercises
correctly at the gym.
I'm not setting my my shoulders back
and engaging my traps whenever
I'm like doing exercises
and my shoulders are
getting hyper extended
but then, her immediate
assessment when I walked in,
why is that confusing?
You're making
a confusing face.
I don't understand.
You're shoulders are hyperextended?
Like, let's just say
I did a bent over row,
like I'm been over facing the ground
and then I'm gonna pull
some weights up to my side.
I'm going to, you know.
You use too much shoulder
and not enough back?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You got to set your shoulders,
roll your shoulders back
and down to engage your lats
in order to then protect your shoulders
so that they don't hyperextend out.
Okay.
But then when I go in there,
she's immediately assessing
my posture and everything.
I walk out of there the first time
with like special flip-flops.
She gave you special flip-flops?
Well, she sold me
special flip-flops that--
How can a flip-flop be special?
Your foot nestles around the
arch in such a way as to--
Reduce the flop?
Invite your heel to be in the right place
so that you're not putting your,
if you watch people walking,
you see people walking, they put weight
on the right side of their
heel, on the left side.
They're not centering their weight.
And I'm sure you've heard this.
If you're not walking correctly,
if your feet aren't interacting
with the terrain correctly,
it has a ripple effect
through your whole body.
That's right to your brain.
Any physical therapy
will tell you that everything
is connected in your body.
So I go in there for my shoulder.
So, do they flop though?
What, my feet?
The flip-flops, do they flop?
Yeah, they flop.
Okay.
You got a problem with flopping?
No, I just thought that,
I don't understand
mechanically how they work
and I thought that maybe like, if they--
When my heels strikes--
Well, these only flop
if you're walking wrong.
They trained me to, when my heel strikes
to distribute the weight
centered on the heel
and not to the right--
How come I haven't seen you wearing these?
Especially, my right foot.
I wear 'em around the house.
I'd like you to wear 'em in.
And when in a physical therapy.
I'd like you to wear the flip-flops in.
I have them in my bag, I wear 'em home.
They fashionable?
It's not really warm
enough but no, they're not,
they're just black.
Okay.
I'd like to get into my story.
You're raising a lot
of questions as you go.
That's all I gotta say.
The main thing about my,
I mean, she's working on my posture
and holding my shoulders
back and my head back
so I'm not hunched over.
So, I'm filling my lungs with air
and I'm puffing my chest out
and I'm being proud to be who I am.
She says things like that to me.
And then she lays me
down on this log of a,
a fitness log, I call it.
It's just a long Styrofoam cylinder
and I lay on that on my back
and then I splay my arms out
and I lay there for 15
minutes doing snow angels.
This is my task.
And I've supposed to do this everyday.
Flip-flops and snow angels.
Yeah, I'm looking good.
And it's basically to open
up, bring my shoulders back,
they flop, if you wanna flop,
my shoulders flop down on
either side of the fitness log
and my arms go out so
my chest opens up, okay?
And it stretches my pecs
and everything's kind of closing down.
I need to just open it back up.
And after doing this a few days,
second day I'm going there, I'm like,
I've got a hitch in my giddyup.
When I laid down on this log
and I start doing the snow angel,
when I get my arms right here
at like two and 10 o'clock,
I feel this pain in my chest,
like right around here.
On one side?
On the right side but then it goes
all the way back to my shoulder blades.
She says, "Well, that
sounds like your rib."
And I'm like, "Well, I do have this rib
"that kinda sticks out right here."
Wanna put my arm?
You might be able to
see it, don't touch it.
I gotta touch it.
I'm going to touch it gently, right there.
Do you feel that?
Not on the other side as much.
It's more on this side.
Yeah, on the right.
I mean I would say that's a mild.
I remember my mom telling
me that I had a fused rib.
I didn't know what that meant.
And she said maybe that's it.
But then she started feeling of it
and it's like right here
to the right of my sternum
in the middle of my chest above my nipple
towards the middle.
It just feels like the ribs poking out.
And so I'm laying there
and she starts just doing what you did.
She immediately starts
feeling of it and rubbing it
and I just started,
I started squirming.
I would have started laughing.
When they touch my chest
like they're doing a massage
and then they turned me over
and they started working the
top of the shoulders and they,
anytime the little--
It tickles.
Little fingers like get down
into the top of the pecs.
I'm like .
Well, let me tell you.
Just embarrass myself.
I started laughing and
I did embarrass myself
and it was like .
It's so embarrassing to laugh.
I wasn't actually, it was
uncomfortable laughter.
It's the same type of
laughter that I exude
when people start
talking about blood flow.
You know that freaks me out.
Yeah.
And I was like .
Like a grunting laughter
kind of like squirming
getting away from her.
And she's like pushing on
my rib and like she's--
Was she responding to your laughing?
And before she could respond,
I was like, "I'm sorry for laughing.
"It just makes me really uncomfortable.
"I actually feel queasy
when you touch it."
And then she said, "You touch it."
And I was like, "I don't
like touching that spot."
I don't like touching that rib.
I never touch it because
it makes me feel queasy.
I don't like touching
that pointy spot.
And she took some ointment.
This is LA, she took some CBD ointment.
She took my hand out, she
put ointment on my hand,
and then she said, "Just rub it."
And I'm like I put my hand under my shirt.
Why is this such,
I understand like rubbing,
actually, I can't think
of a part of my body
that it would be weird for me to rub.
It's like I'm trying,
having someone else rub
it, but me rubbing my body,
the whole point of being ticklish--
It's my kryptonite.
The ticklishness comes
from the unexpected nature,
not being able to anticipate
what's gonna happen next
but you can't you tickle yourself.
We talked about this on the show.
I'm not tickling myself,
I'm making yourself--
You're freaking yourself out
touching your own rib.
I'm freaking myself out.
Yeah, because I feel
like it's not in place
and like I'm touching it,
I just feels gross to me
because it sticks out, man.
It's nasty.
You got lots of things
that stick out though
like all of them.
So, I start touching it
and I try to be obedient
and I'm like I'm rubbing
this spot and I'm like,
she can tell I'm really uncomfortable
and she starts giving me this speech.
She says, "That rib is not mobile.
"You get the pain all the
way to the front and the back
"because it doesn't like to
move like all the other ribs.
"Something's happened to you in the past."
And I told her I broke my pelvis.
She was like, "We might have done it then
"when you busted your
ass and broke your pelvis
"and got a concussion in college."
And I said, "Well, whenever it is,
"I still don't like touching it."
And she's like, "You need to
invite that rib to the party.
"He doesn't have to eat anything
"but it does have to show up."
She's saying all this while--
This is the analogy?
She goes into that many
layers of the analogy?
She goes into that many layers why--
Whether or not the rib has to eat?
Yeah, while I'm rubbing my own chest.
This woman's a genius.
She is trying to distract you.
She got you thinking about
how weird her analogy was
and next thing you know,
you're rubbing that rib.
I'm rubbing that rib and it's a party.
I can rub it now.
And she said, I mean it's
still a little uncomfortable
as I'm trying to do it but she's like,
"You know what, I understand
that it makes you queasy
"but this is part of your body
and your brain is telling you
"that something's wrong with it
"and you need to get comfortable
with it being the way it is
"before we can see some progress."
Hold on, but how we gonna fix it?
Doesn't have to eat but
it needs to go the party.
Do want me to push hard on it?
She pushed hard on it,
don't you push on it.
I think I can distract you,
tell you a little bedtime story
about the rib going to
the party and then boom!
Like it's scaring somebody
when they got hiccups.
I'll just press it in real
quick with a lot of force
and it'll dislodge.
Let me do it.
I have a physical therapist.
Her name is Jane, she
tells me wonderful stories
about rib people.
But she didn't get it,
she didn't fix it.
It takes time.
I gotta say, the--
Mentally, this is like
mental therapy too, dude.
Well, it's kinda reminiscent--
I bet you have a rib that
needs to come to a party.
That's exactly what I was about to say.
I bet you if I went to this woman,
she would find a rib that
needed to go to a party as well
because I think, nothing against her,
I think this might be a little bit
like chiropractic medicine,
which I understand that there's benefit
in chiropractic medicine
but there's also a lot of
woowoo in chiropractic medicine
because no matter who you are,
if you go to a chiropractor,
you think they're gonna be like,
you're perfectly in
balance, please go home.
No, they always say, you're a
little bit out of alignment.
Let me do the,
has anyone ever been to a chiropractor
who didn't tell them that
they were out of alignment?
The only chiropractor I went to
is the one we made a commercial for.
Right.
The Cracked Chiropractor.
Look up that commercial
if you're interested.
Well, or don't.
But--
Yeah.
I kinda feel like this is like one leg
is a little bit longer than
the other kind of thing.
No, she was addressing my mental block.
Do you think you really got a rib
that's not coming to the party?
You think that's real?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean it can be loosened up.
How do we get it to come with the party?
Probably touching and pushing on it.
But I have to get a little
more comfortable with that.
How often you're not
touching and pushing on it?
I haven't since the party analogy.
Right now, I'm touching
it a little bit, okay?
I'm touching on it.
I feel like every night, you
need to, you gotta push hard
'cause I think what's gonna happen,
you're gonna be sitting there one night--
You don't know.
You're gonna push and it's gonna go .
And all your problems are gonna go away.
And just like chiropractic,
not just your rib problem,
all your problems are gonna go away.
If you can get that rib in alignment,
everything else in your
body will like domino.
You'd be like a transformer
and you'll be suddenly in great health.
She says that I need to
like put my chin back
and my chest out
looking like this.
I take issue with that too
because I've never thought of you
as a person with that posture.
I think I got much worse posture than you.
You're always sitting upright.
I mean, Link sits upright
all the time, doesn't he?
You're not hunched at all, man.
Like see the difference between this.
No, look at me, I'm always hunched
because I'm a tall boy.
Just because you have problems
doesn't mean I don't have lesser problems
that I'm dealing with.
It's called envy, Rhett.
You have--
When you bringing me down--
I'm telling you that you have good posture
is not called envy.
I'm telling you that if I were
to line up all of my friends
and there was a spectrum of
good posture to bad posture,
just eyeballing it in my brain right now,
you'd be on the top in the good posture.
When I watched--
Now, pointy ribs, you'd
also be up there as well.
When I watched back the vlog
where we were playing
disc golf with tortillas,
I don't even know if that video is out yet
but when I watched the
first shot of that of me
like teeing off and like
throwing the Frisbee tortilla,
I was like man I'm not athletic-looking.
Well, that's a totally different thing.
I'm goofy looking,
like I got a have a more athletic stance.
But that's not your posture.
And I think that's the key.
It's just your technique.
That's the key to my
shoulder getting better
for everything being tight and together.
Looking cooler while doing things
is the key to getting better?
Don't tell me you don't believe that.
I know that's your worldview.
Well, I will say that from
an athletic perspective
that the way that I've always try,
like the way that I tried to figure out
how to swing a golf club was
watching people on television
who knew how to do it.
I was like I don't really
know exactly what's happening
but if I can make my swing look
more like Tiger Woods swing,
then it'll probably
result in something good.
I found this to be true.
So, if you can look at
Frisbee golfers of the world
and be like, I'd love to look like that.
You don't even need to know
exactly what's happening.
You just need to look like them
and you're probably being good shape.
Well, it's gonna start with a party
where my rib is gonna be there.
Are my ribs invited to the party?
Sure, they don't have to eat
but they do need to be there.
Okay, I'm glad we cleared that up.
You have a new shirt on.
I do, this is be your
mythical best and then--
3D, man.
It's got be your mythical
best written under it.
This is like advanced
graphics stuff.
Graphics.
You what I'm saying?
Two graphics in one.
This is like something that me and you
would never come up with
because we think too inside the box
when it comes to graphics.
Yeah.
We'd be like, hold on,
you put another graphic
underneath the graphic.
You need to delete that layer
before we sell this shirt.
That's what we'd say.
In other words, you're
crapping on our merch.
No, no.
I'm saying that that's what makes it cool.
Our merch has gotten way
better since me and you
stopped being the ones figuring out
what was gonna go on this stuff.
Yeah, man, we're so proud of it.
Look at him wearing it.
Mythical.com, check out all the designs
that have unexpected
twists, turns, shadows
and redundancies.
And coming soon to mythical.com,
a shirt that has a built-in
foam rib that you can rub.
It's got a bump.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's got a bump underneath it.
Yeah, rub it to your heart's content
and it says rub here.
And there's also, it comes
with a packet of CBD oil.
Rub here to come to the party.
Dang it!
Okay, maybe we should be
giving more ideas for merch.
It's probably expensive to produce.
You wanna take a look at
some of these questions?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Where are you gonna start?
Let's just start here at the top.
These aren't questions,
these are things that y'all are into.
Amy Smith.
Amy, what are you into?
I love smelling things.
From entire stores like
tire shops or Home Depot
to Windex and Comet, to old
books and old photographs.
The smell of skunks, gas and
even manure don't bother me.
I just love to smell things.
I think this is great because to me,
this is a form of like
being in the moment.
Like you don't typically,
like, I mean the reason that the same
stop and smell the roses is what it is
is because you don't typically do that.
You don't typically stop
and focus on the scent of something.
I mean if something is pungent
or it's eliciting something
that is a like a warning,
it triggers a warning in your nose.
Like, oh my gosh, somebody
farted, I got to get away
but if something smells good,
it's like, oh that smells good
but I'm just gonna , I'm gonna suck it in.
This is a meditative
mindfulness type of a thing.
But the thing I really
relate to in this, Amy,
is your desire not just
to smell good things
but just to smell things, right?
Yeah.
And I think that one of
the things that I enjoy
is strong flavors, like I think that
anybody who likes black
licorice kinda understands it.
Is it that you actually
think that it tastes good
or you're into that,
you talked about it on
the podcast or on GMM,
the taste masochism.
The concept of you're a
masochist when it comes to taste
and you like strong flavor.
You like bitter, you like
blue cheese and black licorice
and I think the reason
I like those things--
It's simulating danger but
in the confines of safety.
It's like eating a poison berry
without the consequences
of the poison, right?
But it's an experience and
these last three things
that you that you mentioned,
skunks, gas and manure
are like, that might be my top three.
I mean, like---
Well, it depends on the
type of animal manure.
No, but you know like,
what they used to do it--
Like a pig manure, no, thank you.
Cow manure, yeah.
But you know
what they used to do at NC State
where they'd bring in the fresh mulch
that had the manure mixed into it?
Yeah.
And you can tell,
like, oh, there's this high smell.
That's a cow shit.
And it's like, ooh, there's
fresh manure on campus today
and it's like, some people
like, "What's that smell?
"It stinks."
I'm like, "I like it."
I like it, I hate it and
that's why I love it.
I don't know what it is.
It's an evocative experience.
A skunk, well, my dad used to say,
"That's a dead polecat
when you smell a skunk
"when you're just driving down the road."
Because apparently, when a skunk dies--
Dies.
It releases its glands, I don't know.
Yeah, and also it just
stinks because it's dead.
I definitely like smelling of a book.
I always like that.
Books are nice.
I do not smell my toenails.
I do.
I do not smell the inner workings
of my bellybutton, usually.
That would be difficult,
I'm not that flexible.
With your finger.
You mean stick and then pull and smell?
Yeah.
Sample and smell?
Sticking, rim and smell, rimming out.
I don't think my bellybutton smells bad.
Well, I don't--
Let me find out.
Oh, yes, find out.
Well, let's let you find out.
It's most totally fine.
I don't smell anything.
This smells like finger.
Well, listen, you've got
a sample size of one day.
You need to do this every day.
Do you, during your really meticulous
lathering routine that you
do with the shower not going,
do you always lather everything
including the belly button?
Yes.
I cannot tell you the last
time I washed my belly button
or my legs.
That's gross, man.
It's not gross, they smell fine.
Smell my legs, smell my bellybutton.
I'm not gonna smell your legs.
I'll put my legs or my belly
button up against anybody's
and I bet you, they're just as fine.
Well, you need to ask permission
first before you do that.
I wash all crevasses in my face.
And I feel like I'm doing good.
You wash your toes?
Weekly.
Well then, that's a bunch of crevices.
I know.
That's four crevices there.
The thing is that I'm just--
On each foot.
I feel like you're drying
your stuff out, man.
Showers are not even a natural thing.
Sarah, what is the Flame Princess,
as her moniker on Twitter
says, what is she into?
Bones, but more specifically
and this may seem effed up, human bones.
Okay.
I want a human skull more
than words can express.
There's something about
facing your own mortality
by looking into the empty eye sockets
of a once living person
and seeing yourself.
Oh, this is,
is this wicked or is this insightful?
Well, again, I know I'm a dark person
but I very much relate to this as well
and I when we went to--
Human skull.
Went to the Voodoo Museum in New Orleans.
And I guess I'd recommend it.
Well, it's not much of a time commitment.
Right.
It's like a 13-minute--
Pretty much in and out.
And we were really squeezing
all the juice out of that experience.
And there are several human bones,
animal bones but definitely human bones
including some human skulls.
And I gotta say, there is something very--
We were trying to figure
out if they were real
and we did conclude because
they were just out there.
I mean this is like a house
that you walk through.
Well, the human skulls were in,
the one that me and you and
Britain were looking at--
Was in a glass box?
Yeah, it was in a glass box but--
That one was real.
It was real, man.
Yes, like the detailing on that thing.
I get this.
I didn't process it much at that time.
How would you get a human skull?
You gotta kill somebody.
That's the first thing.
How'd you do it legally?
I wonder.
How does one acquire a human skull?
Yeah, I'm sure you, well, legally, okay.
Jen, can you look that up?
Yeah.
Do you feel like you need to go
into incognito mode or something?
Let's see if the work computer
allows me to search this.
Go on the dark web.
You can do it, I know that
you can get a human skull
if you're a medical professional.
How does one acquire a human skull?
Like, if you're a teacher,
you can have a skeleton in your classroom.
I know majority those are fake, just molds
but I'm pretty sure--
Yeah, why it need to be real?
Because it's cooler.
It is cool.
This was a person and now,
they just hang out in this
classroom all the time.
So you're into this.
You're into what Sarah's
into, human bones.
I get it.
I definitely,
I don't know if I would've been into it
until she said that it helps
her face her own mortality
by looking into the empty eye sockets,
I think that kind of redeems it.
Oh, Jen has--
Jen has found something.
An interesting face.
What did you find?
There's a website.
Etsy?
Can I say the website?
Yeah.
It's called the Bone Room.
The Bone Room.
theboneroom.com?
boneroom.com.
I don't know what happens
if you put the the in there.
Well, how much for a human skull?
And how do you it's real?
Normal human skull?
What do you mean a normal human?
Yeah, no, an--
They have other options.
I don't want abnormal human skull.
I don't mind.
That's like a--
I want a extra big one.
That's creepy on creepy.
Okay.
At least $2,000.
Starting price, $2,000.
Wait, there's one that was for 400.
I don't know--
Well, who's was that?
Do they have names?
This is Henry.
The 400 one was an
antique, uncut male skull.
Antique, uncut male skull for 400 bucks?
So these are just like skulls
that are out there on the market.
All right.
That's what I'm gonna
get Rhett for Christmas.
I'm going to get one.
I want one.
Just forget I said that.
I'll get it for your birthday.
Okay, I'll be happy.
Let's move on to another
because I'm creeped out.
Marcel van Werkhoven.
Okay.
I'm into puppets.
I like building, performing
and watching them.
I think they're really cool
'cause they have this weird
ability to connect with people
that I feel even sometimes people can't.
That's probably why people
find them to be creepy.
Hmm.
Puppets.
Okay, so you--
There's a lot that could
be said about puppets.
When you read I'm into puppets
and you stop there for
a second I was like,
okay, that's all I need to
hear, it's not a good idea.
And then he goes on, I like building,
performing and watching them.
Okay, this dude, we're
gonna rip this guy to shreds
for his love of puppets
but now, he's an actual,
he's a creator--
We're not going to rip
anybody to shreds, fam.
Marcel is freaking real-life Geppetto.
He's crafting puppets,
performing and watching
other people perform with them.
So we gotta be careful.
Well, my assessment of puppet loving.
Well, let me rephrase it.
Because my initial
reaction is, uh-uh.
My assessment of being into puppets
is that we are in magic territory here.
We did a whole episode about this.
You mean magician territory?
Yeah, magician territory.
Yeah, and that is being into puppet cool?
Let me think about that
for a split second, no.
Is being a magician cool?
Look at Jen.
"Dark Crystal" is so cool.
Hold on, listen.
Let me finish.
Jen is saying "Dark Crystal"
is cool.
No, "Dark Crystal" but--
She getting offended.
Okay, hold on, you're talking
about like Jim Henson,
you're talking about like
next level labyrinth shit.
We're not talking about
that, we're just talking,
I mean, I don't know, I
haven't seen Marcel's puppets
but I'm just saying the
decision to get into puppets
is like the decision to get into magic
and just like I said,
you don't get into magic
or get into puppets because being
into either one of those things is cool
in the very superficial
traditional sense of what cool is.
You get into it because there's something
that you like to do but
you need to understand
that because of the way society works,
you will be perceived in a
certain way by certain people
if you get into these things.
And you just got to be
ready to embrace that.
I just wonder how many
opportunities there are
for public puppet work these days.
I mean there's--
It's just got to be about
the love of puppets because
the people that break through in puppetry,
this very small percentage of people.
We knew a guy.
Do you remember
a few years ago,
we knew this guy, he was
like a friend of a friend,
he had the big gauged ears.
I don't remember this.
And he was a puppet man
and he worked for Jim Henson
and he taught our kids,
like puppets at, or art or
something at the homeschool co-op
that the kids were a part of.
Okay, okay.
That dude, first of all, he
was the coolest puppeteer
so maybe I'm taking everything back.
He had large gauges.
Like the kind that you could
hang a puppet on each ear.
Okay.
If you wanted to.
And you could stick a puppet finger,
maybe you can stick a puppet hand
depending on the puppet through his ear.
Oh, yeah?
And I feel like if you
can stick a puppet's arm
through your own ear, then you're cool
whether you do puppets or not.
like if Fred Rogers' Daniel the Tiger
can jump through your ear
hole, then you're cool?
Yeah.
Okay.
And the thing about it is if
you've got large gauged ears,
which is not something
that I personally recommend
but it's not something that
I personally judge either.
Making my ears is itchy.
I'm gonna take that
rib that's sticking out
and we'll pull it out
and stick it right through
your ear make a gauge.
Shut up.
If you are the kind of
person that has gauged ears,
you should balance that
with being into puppets
and if you are into puppets,
you should balance that
with being doing something
like getting crazy piercings.
Now, claymation--
A pierced puppeteer, that's
a whole thing right there.
I'ma go to that website.
I think claymation, that's cool.
piercedpuppets.com, is that a website?
Can you look that up?
Oh, boy.
Pierced puppets.
I mean you're back into voodoo
at that point, aren't you?
Oh, you mean like, yeah, voodoo doll.
Lara Bencroft, @mixed_veggies_
is into brushing my teeth
in the, not my teeth.
Lara's into brushing
her teeth in the shower.
Anything at piercedpuppets.com?
Nothing yet.
I moved on because I wasn't hopeful.
You ever brush your teeth in the shower?
I used to.
I have strong opinions about this now
but you go first because
you're the shower man.
I'm the shower man?
Yeah.
Well, I mean, every second in the shower
is just water down the drain a--
Unless you turn it off while you lather.
Which I do that.
Yeah, so like doing more
stuff in the shower to like,
I don't know, I don't like
wasting that amount of water
even though we're not in a drought here
in Los Angeles anymore.
Well, it's interesting because
here's I was gonna say.
As someone who doesn't turn
off the water to lather
but also as I indicated,
my lathering process
is not nearly as thorough as Mr. Neal's,
therefore, it doesn't take
me but about 17 seconds.
So that's not a lot of water.
Yeah, it probably gets washed off
before it's actually caught the nasties.
I stepped out of the stream to lather
and then I get back into the stream
but that being said, I
used to brush my teeth
in the shower in North Carolina.
You're surrounded by water there.
It's like there's ponds
every four feet, creeks,
it's like you don't get
a sense that the water
is in short supply when
you're in North Carolina.
Right.
And, I mean, ever seen Jordan Lake?
Full of water except when it wasn't.
And so, I would brush
my teeth in the shower
but two things have changed.
Number one, I've moved to
California where I've been,
sort of, you can't--
The drought, yeah.
You can't avoid being more conscious
about the water supply.
But also, this is, I don't
know if there are sponsor
on this episode but quip,
because I'm using the quip toothbrush
and I'm brushing for two minutes,
which is how long you should be brushing.
Yeah.
Two minutes of brushing in the shower
for a man who's not gonna
turn the water supply off.
Yeah, that's irresponsible.
I just moved it, I'm completely moved it
to a different part of my day.
I don't like the idea--
Or different part of the morning.
Keeping my toothbrush in the shower.
I don't like the idea of
other people's showering
and yeah, that's just my wife but yeah,
I don't know my wife's
stuff rebounding off my--
Offage, your wife's offage?
Yeah, where she's like,
and then getting on my toothbrush.
Does your wife lather as much as you do?
I'm sure she doesn't,
that would be impossible.
Does she have a shower system?
I haven't asked her because
I don't want to have a fight.
Hold on, y'all never shower together?
Rhett, when we shower together,
it's not as much about getting cleaned.
In fact, it's quite the opposite.
Hold on, hold on.
But has there ever been--
A time when we're just like both
independently in the
shower just showering?
Just washing?
No.
Really?
There's been a couple of times,
I mean I'm not--
When it's like she's got to shower
and you've got a shower,
there's not any shower play?
Less than a dozen times
during 19 years of marriage.
We have showered at the same
time because of convenience,
not because of other desires.
Okay.
There have been those scenarios
where you know, shower play.
But what I'm talking about
is showering at the same time
because you both need
to get into the shower--
Why is that what you're talking about?
Because the other thing
is the interesting thing to talk about.
Well, hold on.
Let's talk about sex in the shower.
Hold on, hold on but--
Right, everybody?
Well, okay, well, I was
trying not to talk about that.
It's dangerous.
You gotta be careful about your--
I'm not moving on, I'm gonna
keep coming back to this.
Well, I'll talk about it when you're done.
But the fact that I
think that your routine,
your shower routine is so regimented
that no one else could fit into it anyway.
First of all, your shower
has two independent shower heads.
Your shower is built for
two people to take a shower
at the same time, am I right?
Well, the current house I'm in
but other homes that I've
lived in, that was not a case.
Oh.
And I still did it.
What would y'all do?
Just alternate who's under the water?
Yeah.
You might as well just wait
until she's done at that point.
Well, sometimes, you do
like a Patrick Swayze
in "Ghost" kind of thing.
Like she might be lathering
and you might come up
behind her, help her lather.
Okay, so now you're talking about--
No, no, but it's for function.
I mean it's a little sensual
but it doesn't have to
be sensual or practical,
it can be both.
In fact, when it's both, it's beautiful.
Where the sensual meets the practical.
It sounds like a tagline for a class
that you would see at a yoga studio
that you could tear off in Los Angeles.
Yeah, yeah.
Shower play, where
sensual meets practical.
It's way to tight quarters
to just be in the shower
together just to be clean.
You've got a big shower.
I've been in it.
Yeah, and I was in there too.
Right, it's not tight quarters.
Yeah, but I don't know, it just seems like
that's a personal space unless it's,
unless you're sorting the mail.
If you're sorting the mail
in the shower together,
then go for it but like I
said, you got to be calculated
about you got to have a
good foot hold or hand hold.
You got to, you just can't--
I don't play that game.
The height difference is too
extreme for that to be safe.
Yeah, it's always been,
for me, it's always been,
I mean it's always rewarding,
I'm not gonna say that,
but it's almost like it's too challenging.
And the level of dangers
and potential personal injury involved
with like slippage and stuff,
it's just, there's too much
anxiety associated with it.
I mean you don't wanna
have that much pressure.
That's not good for performance.
Performance.
I'm just not into making
love in the shower.
Okay, that is what this has become.
But brushing your teeth,
you're also not into
which was the original.
I liked that in principle
but I gotta remember to
bring my toothbrush in
and then put it away because
I like it in my drawer
so it's not out.
I don't like leaving my toothbrush out.
Next.
Next thing that someone is into
from BYM Beth, I like that.
That's cool.
I'm really into going to show homes
that I know I'll never buy.
Oh, like an open house.
It's purely just out of nosiness.
You see the sign, the house is for sale.
A lot of cars parked around here.
Oh, they're all going
into this open house.
Now, you know that this is my dad,
this is my dad's past time, really.
Growing up, we just,
we'd find houses that were--
I knew that you would
drive around neighborhoods
just to drive around
neighborhoods and look at houses.
And to go into houses
that were open houses.
Okay, okay.
In fact, when they came out
here a couple years ago,
we went into like a really
nice neighborhood somewhere
and somewhere in town
where there's like
multi-million dollar homes,
like up in the hills and you just go,
on a Sunday afternoon, drive around
and you get to walk into
these awesome houses.
Those levels of houses--
That's fun.
Still have open home policy things?
They let just people
walk in off the street?
Yeah.
Oh, I didn't know that.
I mean, maybe not like,
I'm not talking about
like a $20 million home.
I'm talking about like a $4 million home.
Okay.
Which in the Hollywood Hills
or something like that.
I mean, there's some interesting stuff.
I've done it a couple of times.
So you tell me how you've dealt
with this because my thing--
Whether I use the bathroom or not?
Yeah, one time, I did.
My thing is you go in there
and there's a real estate agent
who kinda greets you at the door
and there's like, they're
giving out handouts
with all the information on
the house to potential buyers.
I know I'm not a potential buyer
in the few times that I've done this
but I found myself acting
like a potential buyer
as opposed to just saying,
I'm just here to look around.
I think they can look in your eyes,
they've done this long enough
that they're good at it
and they're selling the houses
that are worth walking through
to know in a split instance
whether you're there as a potential buyer
or just to look around
because like BYM Beth,
you're just into it.
But I found myself just
instinctively lying.
Oh, yeah, so what are the comps?
It's like go into the kitchen,
there's another agent.
The kitchen agent.
These nice houses, they got
double teaming with agents.
And they're baking bread
just to make the house smell like it.
Yeah, yeah, they got
tricks up their sleeve.
They sell a--
Candle?
Well, they sell candles
that smell like baked bread
but they sell this thing that
looks like a loaf of bread
that has an oil in it
and you put it in the oven
when you're showing a home
and it makes your whole
home smell like baked bread
but you don't really have to
bake bread, it's just oil.
And if you turn the light on for the oven,
you can see the bread.
It looks like bread.
How do you even know about this?
Because I was in a home
one time where they had it
and Jessie was like talking
to somebody who was--
Like an open house?
Yeah.
Whoa.
And I don't know if this is
like really hit it big yet.
Jen, could you look that up?
She don't need to look that up.
Jen, don't look that up.
No, because if no one--
Don't waste your fingers.
Please, look it up.
Fake baked bread oven
smell home.
I don't search--
Are you like giving clues and password?
Do we have a game?
That's what I do.
You telling me you search
actual questions into Google?
I just put all the keywords.
Google will assemble the answer.
Three would have been plenty.
I don't know, I think
I had to give it home.
Fake bread oil would have been enough.
No, that wouldn't have enough,
that would just give you fake bread oil.
Okay, yeah.
10 clever ways to make your home
smell like you've been baking.
Yeah.
But where do you buy one?
But is there a website?
Fakebread.com.
It all like hack on like
putting vanilla in stuff.
We've come up with--
This is hacks, this isn't a product.
Three good business ideas.
When you go into a house, do you tell him,
I'm just looking around.
Amazon's got it.
Or do you start lying like I do?
Oh, bread oil.
Fresh bread spray.
Fresh bread, oh, that's
a little different.
The thing I talking about,
you put in the oven.
Like a ceramic bread
that you drizzle oil on.
Yeah, so, I typically have
an initial conversation
that makes it seem--
Like they don't need to
waste their time on you?
If they're like, you're looking,
so you guys interested in buying?
If they ask that question, I be like,
"You know, yeah, eventually."
So you do lie.
Well, that's true.
I am eventually gonna buy a house.
In the hills?
Somewhere.
Okay.
You know.
But you're lying.
You're not looking to
that house to buy it.
You know me though.
I could go up--
But when you say okay--
I could go up for a Sunday
afternoon just for kicks
and next thing you know,
I'm like with a lawyer
and buying the thing just
because I'm so impulsive
but no, I'm just saying,
because I want them to, well--
Sell it to you.
I don't want them to,
I want a perfect balance.
I don't want them to look at me
like I wish he wasn't
in here walking around,
he's just wasting my time.
And I also don't want
them to interact with me
and try to follow me around the house.
I'm just in there, I prefer
them to not be there.
I'm just there to explore.
So you say something that keeps them
from giving you dirty
looks but also is like,
I don't think he's serious,
I'm not gonna follow him around,
I'm not gonna ask him questions.
That's the balance that you want.
But they know.
They know the deal.
But I do get this.
It is fun to look at homes,
especially when you like--
It's actually a fun afternoon.
When you're lying to
like a real estate agent,
that is fun.
It's actually a good,
I suggest this like creative date.
A creative date and this could sometimes,
this think might move things
a little forward too fast
if you're not actually serious
but you're dating somebody,
I would say if you've dated somebody
for more than two months
and less than one year
because after one year, it's
not any fun anymore to do this.
Okay.
Pretend that you're a married
couple looking for a home.
Two months of dating?
You're gonna pretend you're married?
Listen, you know me.
I think like I'm in a movie, man.
I'm not gonna do the long
play, the slow play thing.
It's like, I'm like, yeah, it's
like it's actually to like--
You're not gonna do anything
because you're married.
I'm talking about the
proverbial me that's not married
and one time, wasn't married.
This is the kind of thing
that I would have done with Jessie.
The fantasy single Rhett?
I'm saying that this is a good idea
because it's kind of like a role play,
to feel like it what it
would be like to be a couple.
And then you what?
Go into the shower and
sort the mail together.
No, you can't use the shower
but I have urinated at an open house
but I've never taken a dump.
Yeah, you better hope
that have bread oil is in the bathroom.
You gonna have to take a dump, man.
Somebody's been baking bread in here
if you know what I mean.
Somebody's been baking
some pumpernickel in here.
Why you--
Baking some pumpernickel
because it's dark brown.
And you have to pump it?
Baking some pumpernickel
is like a dookie, man.
Because it's dark.
That was a good joke
and most people got it.
Okay.
Let's go to the next page.
Yeah, yeah, I agree with that.
We just skipped someone's because it--
It wasn't good enough.
What you're into sucked so
bad that we just skipped it.
We're not even gonna tell you about it.
Amy replied to our prompt and said,
"I really love eating burnt toast.
"I purposely burned my toast
so it'll be nice and crunchy.
"It just has better flavor, to be honest."
She spelled the flavor with a U
which means that she's
probably from the UK
or somewhere over on
that side of the pond.
She's not American.
Or she just doesn't know
how to spell flavor.
Do you like burnt toast?
Do you think I like burnt toast?
Do you wish I like burnt toast
because you know I don't?
I would be willing to
bet many, many dollars
that you don't like burnt
toast because you don't,
you differentiate between
the darkness of biscuits.
I want a light biscuit.
Every time we go to Bojangles'
or anything with a biscuit,
it's like, you will hear--
Listen, man.
You will hear this phrase.
Can you give me a light biscuit?
Hey, listen, I don't get
to go Bojangles' often.
It's a man--
And when I go to Bojangles'
I'm like--
Who is so particular
that he has a biscuit preference.
Yeah, I don't mean the type of biscuit,
I mean the lightness of a biscuit.
Like the opposite of pumpernickel biscuit.
Right.
So, yeah, man.
I don't know what a Bojangles' that often.
I mean they're not out
here so when I go back home
and I'm gonna maximize
my Bojangle experience,
I want it to be what I want it to be,
I want it to be a light biscuit.
That's not my impression.
My impression isn't that you--
I don't know the--
You're trying to maximize,
is that you would not enjoy the biscuit
if it was a dark biscuit.
My favorite--
You're a racist against biscuit
and you're afraid to admit it.
My favorite burger is a Shake Shack burger
and time before last I went there
and I was eating a burger and I was like,
something's missing.
This is amazing but it
could be more perfect.
It's missing onions.
If you order just like
the Shake Shack burger,
there's no onions.
You got to get the he Smoke Stack.
That has--
Peppers, they're awesome.
They have peppers.
They are good but it's like,
I like the just the classic
taste as well with onions
and I had to make a mental note.
Next time I go in there,
I'm gonna add the onions.
This is my experience.
Caramelized or?
Yeah, caramelized.
Okay.
They said, "We don't have that
"but we got something else
like that, it has onions."
Like yeah, that's what
I mean, give it to me.
Did you stop midway through
the burger and get 'em?
I thought about that time before last
but then I just made a mental note
and never make that mistake again
and I did the same thing
with light biscuits years ago
and I've never looked back.
I don't like burnt toast
because it's burnt.
Burnt is a pejorative term.
But if you like that, that's cool for you.
Jack's bread.
Okay, let me give you my perspective on,
I'm going to use a pan of brownies
to make an analogy, okay?
So we're not talking toast,
we're talking brownies.
Fine.
And again, I think that
this is my philosophy
about most things in life.
This is confusing but fine.
So you got a pan of brownies
and you've got people who
like the middle brownie
and you got people who like edge brownies,
you got people who like
corner brownies, right?
Yeah.
And then the way that I
look at the brownie pan
isn't to like, well, I'm
a middle brownie man,
I'm a corner brownie man,
I'm an edge brownie man.
Honestly, the way I interact
with the pan of brownies
is what kind of brownie
man am I right now?
And sometimes it'll be like--
You just look to me like
you were totally crazy.
So it's like you're saying
something that's a good point
but you looked at me like you were crazy.
I just think it makes
life more interesting
to not come to the conclusion
of what kind of brownie man
you are and just be like,
I'm gonna go for the middle
and enjoy the gooeyness
and then I'm gonna go for the corner
and I'm gonna get that crispy
and I'm gonna enjoy it.
And so--
Listen, some of us are Optimus Prime
and some of us have--
And I'm just saying--
A loser.
I feel like approaching toast in that way
makes it so that it's like, sometimes,
especially when you're not in control
because you're not,
I mean you're not in control
of most of your meals.
I mean you're definitely not in control
of most your meals, right?
'Cause you don't cook, so therefore--
I think I could cook toast if I had to.
I'm just saying that
if you open yourself up
to the world of both light
biscuits and dark biscuits,
then you might appreciate the
darkness and the lightness
and create a biscuit balance in your life.
So all that to say--
I like soft things, not crunchy things.
I like--
Sometimes, I'm in a burnt toast mood.
Undercooked things, not burnt things.
I get it, and you know
what, burnt popcorn,
that can be good too.
But it probably causes cancer.
Here's a weird one.
I don't like burnt chicken on the grill
but I like a nice
charred piece of chicken.
That tastes good to me.
But what if the meat gets dry?
That's not good.
Yeah, a catch-22.
Okay, Amanda Marie, you're up.
She says I collect caution
tape from construction sites
that she passes.
Okay, this is a problem.
I even have two pieces from crime scenes
with officer permission.
And then she tweeted again
after she like thought about
what we were probably gonna say
and she's like, "I guess
I should explain it.
"I collect it because it reminds me
"of all the places I've
seen in the world."
Well, you only go to construction
sites and crime scenes
all around the world?
Oh, they are all around the world.
I even have some in other languages.
It's a unique way to document my life.
Yeah, it is unique, I'll
give you that, Amanda Marie.
Caution tape from construction sites
and then two pieces from crime scene.
First of all--
So the officer permission
really only applies--
It's a crime scene.
I'm trying to play Sherlock Holmes here.
Yeah, she's going on construction sites
and taking down the stuff that
then people mindlessly walk
into construction sites into pits
and a plethora of problems.
Well, listen, I mean this is a--
You're endangering people.
Let me just make--
With your hobby.
A couple of observations
about Amanda Marie, okay?
So, Amanda Murray, her Twitter name,
amanda marie, bleak creek,
her Twitter name is @lostmythicality
and then in her actual profile picture,
she's got a picture with us.
So we know that Amanda
Marie is a good person.
So we know that--
We gotta be, yeah, okay.
No, no.
No, I'm not talking about
just being nice to her.
I'm just saying that I am using
what I know about her to deduce--
She's got great taste in us.
That she is not taking away tape
from like around holes
and stuff like that.
I think this is probably like,
oh, I can tell that this
part of the construction site
is no longer that important.
Like, they finished here but
no one's taking this down yet,
I'm gonna take a little bit of this tape
and add to my large collection
of crime scene tape.
Or she only goes to construction sites
that have officers present
and asks them for permission.
I just don't know how
construction site tape
is different from place
to place enough to then
be able to remember where you were.
I guess language would help.
If you approach this like cont,
then you would ask the question.
One of the ways to figure out
if whether or not your actions
are morally upright is to ask
if everyone were to do what I'm doing,
what would the net effect in the world be?
There'd be a lot less construction tape.
And I believe that if everyone did this,
there would be a lot more
construction accidents
because eventually, you're
gonna get to the good tape.
Yeah.
'Cause everybody else is gonna take it.
So I would have to say that
I would limit my activity
to the crime scenes
with officer permission.
Yeah, so then you're just creepy
but you're not really luring people
into an injurious environment.
But I will say that second one.
The construction tape is
kind of like hmm, okay,
I don't know about that one.
Real-life
crime scene tape--
The crime scene, that's--
That's creepy but--
That's the kind of thing
that I could get into.
Crime scene, do not cross
but you can take a little bit
if you want it.
Yeah, and sometimes, I think
you can talk to an officer
who's got the,
I mean, somebody has the
roll of crime scene tape.
I mean it's coming from somewhere, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So--
Utility belt situation?
But I don't wanna take that
but do you have the roll,
can I have a couple of
squares with your roll?
What is this conversation like?
I mean you're walking
up to the crime scene,
there's officers there.
They're going about
their officer business.
Excuse me, officer.
It's like he's immediately assuming,
it's like what happened here?
Officers got to put up with
that crap of what happened here?
What's going on?
It's like no, no, no.
I don't wanna know what happened,
I just want some of your tape.
Can I have some of the tape?
The what?
So yeah, I collect the tape
from places all around the world
and it helps me remember
where I was when I committed crimes.
It's like all of a sudden, you're suspect.
You know what, it is
exactly the kind of thing--
A suspect--
A serial killer
would do in a movie.
Right.
I always visit the crime
scenes and ask for the tape.
I have a little jovial
exchange with the officer
and you know what those suckers do?
They give me pieces of tape.
Right, we've accused
Amanda of quite a bit here.
But she knows us.
But we know she's a good person.
She haven't done any of that stuff.
You want secret lady spider?
Oh, this is similar to the other one.
I'll put this on there because
I thought you'd be into it.
I'm super obsessed with
abandoned houses and buildings.
I keep a list of ones
near me I want to visit
and marathon content of people
exploring them on YouTube.
Yes!
I take photos of them
and look up their histories of ownership.
I don't know why, I
just think they're neat.
Yeah, I have--
This is Elle.
What?
Her name is Elle.
Oh, I thought you were
beginning to spell something.
This is L-I-N-K, reporting for duty.
I don't know where you were going.
No, I'm sorry, what were you gonna say?
You may have told me
about the YouTube channel
where the guy goes into the old,
there's on that goes to
like old malls and stuff.
We've talked about it on--
There's a number of,
this is a YouTube genre.
Well, and I'll tell you.
More accessible thing because
Elle, I'm with you on this.
There's a Reddit thread
called abandoned porn
and it's not just like old pornography
that's been thrown in the ditch.
We found a bunch of those.
We found a lot of that
growing up.
Yeah.
Once you get to the
middle of the magazine,
it's usually still intact.
Right, right.
you can't tell what--
You get through the soggy cover.
You got to get to the...
That's true.
It's kinda like a pan of
brownies but the exact opposite.
Yeah.
That's right.
Soggy on the outside and
crispy in the middle.
Oh, yeah.
Crispy tot.
Oh, gosh.
A there is a Reddit thread
called a abandoned porn
and yeah, it's just pictures
that people have taken of,
like amazing structures.
I mean, gosh, I mean all types--
There's so much stuff like this
and both of us are really into this.
There was like a ferry and like,
I don't know, down in
the Bayou or something
that was abandoned years
ago and there was a flood
that took this ferry up the river
and then when the flood receded,
it just stayed there and it was like a,
a steam boat with a big wheel in the back.
Steam boat, yeah.
The big big wheel in the back.
Yeah.
The paddle in the back thing.
Paddle steamer.
And somebody posted a photo of it
and then all these
people started commenting
about where it was and how
they'd been to it and every year,
they would go there to
like spend the summer
because it was like near this
like camping area or something
and every year, the
water level would come up
and move the ferry
and then recede so every
year, they would come back
and it would be in a different location.
And every year, it would be
more and more dilapidated
and I actually think it's gone now
but I don't know how these people discover
all these things but--
'Cause you haven't really supposed
to get into a lot of them.
Oh, yeah.
Jessie gave me a book one year--
It's very fascinating.
Like a coffee table book that was,
beautiful pictures of the
inside of abandoned structures
and old hotels and I absolutely love, love
looking at these things
but I haven't been in many.
I think there's a few like old theaters,
well, it wasn't really abandoned
but is it the Pacific Theatre?
Yeah.
It's this one on Hollywood that--
Hollywood Boulevard.
It's the one where one
of the Warner Brothers
like died of a heart attack in the lobby
and it's where the first
Academy Awards was held.
Yeah.
We explored that.
Got on the roof and stuff
because we were with somebody
who had access to the building.
We have permission.
I went downstairs and saw the
giant air conditioning unit
that like super inefficient.
It's like a dinosaur.
With a huge belt, like a
belt that was 20 feet across
and then in one of the,
one of the cool things about touring
was we got to play in
all these old theaters
and we went into the
underbelly of this one theater.
Yeah, that's right.
And I don't know where this
one was but the entire floor
of the theater could be
on these hydraulic jacks
that are like 20, I
mean like 100 years old,
could go up and down.
Could come up to meet the
stage and then go down.
And I don't even know
why it worked that way.
Yeah, I'm into this.
You know what, I bet you there's a good,
I bet you there's some good VR tours
that you can take of these old buildings.
That's good.
if I knew that that would be my rec.
You know what, I'll make this my rec.
If you're on Reddit the thread
is called abandoned porn
and like I'm looking at it right now.
Medical wing of Eastern
State Penitentiary,
Westmoreland glass factory
in Western Pennsylvania.
A castle in New York.
Oh, this one in Bulgaria,
Buzludzha monument,
Kazanlak, Bulgaria.
It's an old soviet monument now guarded
and barred from entry
but it looks like a UFO
landed on the edge of a mountain
with this big obelisk beside it.
It looks like something out of James Bond.
Yeah, they should put that in a movie.
I mean, and then you can read about it
because I don't know, even if
there's only like 10 comments,
one of those people will know about it.
Oh, yeah, it's Reddit.
It's a amazing.
People know things.
'Cause when we were
kids, we would go into--
Old houses.
We would go out into the
woods and there'd be cabins.
Well, next--
In the woods that, there'll be trees
growing all around it,
there'd be no access,
I don't know
how they got there.
Do you remember the,
we went to the cabin.
I know Ben and I went
there but then I think
you and I went there.
In the pasture that we
used to chase cows in
and where the rocks are,
if you were to walk,
like right where you come
into the pasture where we did
when we went to Buies Creek
but you walk all the way across straight
instead of going to the rock
so you go past the rocks
and keep going straight
and going to those woods
and keep walking, there was an old house
that was just sitting in
the middle those woods.
It was like a Hansel and
Gretel type situation
because it was a house that had no path,
no road, no indication
that there ever was a road
because it was so old
that the entire woods
had grown up completely around it.
Any trees had grown up into it
and it was this old house
and we would go in there.
And a lot of, I don't remember
that one but a lot of them,
you go in the kitchen, there
be stuff in the cabinets
and the old--
This one was way beyond
that, like beyond--
Can and stuff and and stuff like that.
But there was the one that
one of our friends brother's,
like exploded with dynamite.
Yeah.
That had like a fully stocked
kitchen with a bunch of
old clothes and stuff.
It was a super creepy.
We had a lot of fun there.
And near my nanny's house, like
I would drive her golf cart
over to this, there was
this abandoned house
and I went in there and
there were hand-drawn murals
on the wall of anatomically-correct women.
Naked.
Anatomically-correct,
it might be pushing it.
Did I show it to you?
No, I'm just saying I remember
the proportions of the,
most of the time, that
portions of the parts were--
No, this is--
Not true-to-life.
This is very accurate.
Really?
it was like a medical drawing?
Yeah, I learned a lot.
Okay.
And it's funny because on
"Dolly Parton's America",
like that podcast series,
she tells the story
of going into--
Learning a lot about sex.
An abandoned church that had,
I don't know what it is
about abandoned homes
that make people wanna draw like,
well, abandoned porn.
Well, you don't wanna do in your own home.
Especially if you're
gonna take a whole wall.
Yeah, where else can you
just draw a naked person
with their legs spread?
You can't do that in your house.
You got to do it in an abandoned house.
Did I say leg spread
or did you remember I
told you that before?
Because I didn't know
if I wanted to say that.
Well, I've got specific memories
of going into abandoned houses
and like going into the
living room like a full--
Yeah, like a fresco.
This is it.
I've never seen a fresco get that fresh.
All right, I think we had a good time.
Yeah, hopefully you've
learned some things.
I think it didn't suck.
I think if there's any apologies owed,
just go ahead and pre-apologize to Marcel.
Yeah, Marcel the puppeteer.
Especially for Link saying
that he was about to rip him a new one.
But that didn't end up happening
because we talked about how the proper way
to approach puppets.
And then maybe you might need,
I don't know if we need to
apologize to Amanda Marie.
We just need to make sure
that she understands her Miranda rights.
True.
We'll speak at you next week.
#EarBiscuits.
To watch more "Ear Biscuits",
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of "Ear Biscuits",
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.